[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing harry potter's arch nemesis
and the son of lucius malfoy draco
malfoy
draco malfoy was a british pureblood
wizard born in the year 1980
the son of narcissa malfoy and death
eater lucius malfoy
draco started at hogwarts in the same
year as harry ron hermione
and many of the other characters that
we're so familiar with right from the
beginning draco exhibits
questionable behavior he's the
archetypal bully
and when he first meets harry in the
film he extends his hand out to him
but not before taking an easy shot at
ron weasley who harry had also just met
think my name's funny do you no need to
ask yours
red hair and a hand-me-down robe you
must be a weasley
harry having already befriended ron is
not a fan of draco's attitude
and when he rejects his handshake it
sparks the catalyst that would result in
years of animosity between the two
jk rowling describes draco's character
as follows
everybody recognizes draco because
everybody has known somebody like him
such people's belief in their own
superiority can be infuriating
laughable or intimidating depending on
the circumstances in which one meets
them
draco succeeds in provoking all of these
feelings in harry
ron and hermione at one time or another
so
right off the bat we sort of get a sense
of the type of character that draco
malfoy is going to be
the only reason that he's interested in
befriending harry is because of his fame
and draco having been raised in a
pureblood family that places an
exceptional amount of value on status
leaps at the opportunity to associate
himself with harry
after the sorting ceremony draco is
placed into slytherin house
and harry is placed into gryffindor this
is basically the beginning of the
rivalry between draco and harry
throughout the books and films draco is
a constant nuisance towards the trio
and as he grows older his behavior turns
from annoying
but still childlike and playful to
rather sinister
draco a pure blood supremacist and
die-hard slytherin jumped at any
opportunity to embarrass or insult
students in
any of the other houses here's another
one of draco's charming lines
addressed towards gryffindor students
you know how i think they choose people
for the gryffindor team
it's people they feel sorry for see
there's potter
who's got no parents then there's the
weasleys who've got no money
you should be on the team long bottom
you've got no brains
but while draco was always troublesome
condescending and just rough to be
around in general
i think that it would be fair to say
that his behavior is largely a product
of his upbringing
i don't think that draco is necessarily
an inherently bad person
he was just raised by a couple of pure
blood supremacists one of them is a
death eater
how would you expect him to turn out the
very atmosphere that draco was raised in
was poisonous
his father having followed lord
voldemort in the first wizarding war
only avoided imprisonment by claiming
that he was under the imperious curse
for the duration of the war
this however was not the case and lucius
lived in constant regret
having been unsuccessful along with the
other death eaters
and bringing lord voldemort to power
image was important to the male voice
and having to claim that you were placed
under the imperious curse even if to
avoid
imprisonment makes you look weak this
weakness
ended up being personified in the form
of even more hatred towards muggleborns
half-bloods half-breeds and blood
traitors draco who was highly influenced
by his father
adopted this same attitude and this
formed the person that we saw at
hogwarts
an attitude that was the product of its
father's failure and extreme prejudice
as draco grew older we witnessed
firsthand his evolution from petulant
but innocent little boy to sinister and
dark young man
what really set him off was the
imprisonment of his father after the
battle of the department of mysteries
a battle that effectively served as the
catalyst and first major conflict
of the second wizarding war after
voldemort yours harry to the department
of mysteries
in an attempt to steal the fabled
prophecy harry comes face to face with
lucius
who up until that point had been able to
somewhat save face within the wizarding
community
oh you don't know potter as i do
bellatrix here's a great weakness for
heroics
the dark lord understands this about him
now give me the prophecy
potter i know sirius is here i know
you've got him
it's time you learn the difference
between life and dreams
potter now give me the prophecy or we
start using ones
because draco's father was seen
participating in the battle as a death
eater
he was sent to azkaban for his crimes
draco was very upset by this
and knowing that harry was involved
swore that he would get retribution
where the pair would previously get back
at each other in the form of harmless
pranks or
jinxes this was the beginning of a new
deeper darker relationship between the
two boys
harry having been attacked by draco's
father resented the malfoys
and draco who felt that harry was
responsible for his father's
imprisonment
presented harry in year six draco had
officially joined the death eaters
replacing his father for the time being
in their ranks
it was during this year that we see
draco in his most sinister skulking form
having been given a special mission by
voldemort kill dumbledore
draco kept a relatively low profile
after joining the ranks of the death
eaters
but couldn't help but brag about being
given a special mission
to his fellow slytherin students on the
train to hogwarts
harry overheard parts of the
conversation and draco
who became aware of harry's presence
after the train stopped used a full body
blind curse to paralyze harry
didn't mummy ever tell you it was rude
to eavesdrop potter
patrifica's totalis just before brutally
stomping on harry's face
and crushing his nose as revenge for his
father's imprisonment
he says the following to harry oh yeah
she was dead before you could wipe the
drool off your chin
this really symbolized the path that
draco had chosen at this point
intent on fulfilling the dark lord's
bidding and avenging his father
what were once harmless quips had become
horrible remarks about harry's dead
mother
over the course of the same school year
draco appears to be more distraught than
ever
completely terrified of failing the dark
lord's mission and embarrassing his
father
what's interesting about draco's mission
however is that it has been implied that
voldemort always expected draco to fail
assigning this mission to draco was
voldemort's way of punishing lucius
for his failure of the department of
mysteries draco was barely present for
classes during this school year
stopped attending quidditch practice and
did not fulfill any of his duties as a
prefect
the same duties that he would previously
enjoy it was obvious that the pressure
was affecting him
as the story progresses we see draco
become more and more involved with the
death eaters
but despite talking the talk it appeared
that draco was almost always hesitant in
performing the duties of the death
eaters
when push came to shove when the trio
were caught by snatches
and draco was called upon to identify
them he was very hesitant in doing so
this is just one of the indicators that
draco didn't actually want to be a death
eater
he just wanted to make his parents proud
he didn't want the people that he went
to school with for years to die
he just wanted to live up to the family
name even if it wasn't
truly him by the end of the books and
films while it is not explicitly stated
or
shown it's rather clear that draco is
remorseful for his actions
and that he was really just the pawn of
his father he was a misguided young boy
that just never knew any different
and i think that harry among others were
able to recognize this towards the end
it's really quite sad actually as
without his father's looming presence
he could have perhaps had a more normal
childhood but you may be wondering
what happened to draco after the battle
of hogwarts as he grew even older
what sort of person did he become jk
rowling after the films ended
expressed that draco had been sobered by
his experiences as a death eater
and in a 2014 entry on pottermore says
the following with regards to draco's
character
the biggest revelation was that he
became less of a pureblood fanatic
the events of draco's late teens forever
changed his life
he had had the beliefs with which he had
grown up challenged in the most
frightening way
he had experienced terror and despair
seen his parents suffer for their
allegiance
and had witnessed the crumbling of all
that his family had believed in
people whom draco had been raised or
else had learned
to hate such as dumbledore had offered
him help and kindness
and harry potter had given him his life
after the events of the second wizarding
war
lucius found his son as affectionate as
ever but refusing to follow the same old
pure bloodline draco married the younger
sister of a fellow slytherin
a story of greengrass who had gone
through a similar though less violent
and frightening conversion from pure
blood ideals to a
more tolerant life view was felt by
narcissa and lucius to be something of a
disappointment as a daughter-in-law
they had had high hopes of a girl whose
family featured on the sacred 28
but as astoria refused to raise their
grandson scorpius in the belief that
muggles were scum
family gatherings were often fraught
with tension also
he seemingly mellowed out a bit leading
a life of leisure instead of working to
overturn the forces of light
or establish dominion over muggles like
lucius did
i imagine that draco grew up to lead a
modified version of his father's
existence
independently wealthy without any need
to work
draco inhabits malfoy manor with his
wife and son
i see in his hobbies further
confirmation of his dual nature
the collection of dark artifacts harks
back to family history
even though he keeps them in glass cases
and does not use them
however his strange interest in
alchemical manuscripts
from which he never attempts to make a
philosopher's stone
hints at a wish for something other than
wealth perhaps even the wish to be a
better man
i have high hopes that he will raise
scorpius to be a much kinder and more
tolerant malfoy than he was in his own
youth
while draco's character is ultimately
one of dubious morality
i like to imagine that over the years he
truly did become a good
sound man in rowling's own words there
is after all
some unextinguished good at the heart of
draco
and that's it for this video i hope you
enjoyed it if you have any questions
please let me know down in the comment
section below
until next time remember it does not do
to dwell on dreams
and forget to live